I agree with you Doug I'd like to shake
your hand sir here we go oh no no oh no
no it's just it's just a handshake yeah
it's just a handshake yeah all right
you're welcome in Black je anytime well
all right well thank you my my my
brother you now maybe I'll start a show
for you to come on and we'll call it lot
Jeopardy we don't need it we don't need
it so to e if you guys see uh Saturday
Night Live any of that they had their
50th Anniversary recently no I saw some
YouTube ads but that was about it been
trending a lot a lot of their personas
and things in the news and Tom Hanks got
really slammed I guess by their moniker
Maga make America great again is how
they're being described but lots of
people who are Republican or or
sympathize with the party because of the
skit that he did and he was on um Black
Jeopardy skit that they did as and he
was wearing a a make America great again
hat and he talked you know like a
southern accent and you know really kind
of played up the part he appeared to not
shake the hand of the host who was
African-American and so they're looking
at like this is racist and they're
portraying uh those supporters or people
that would um identify with that as
racist people I think when you see
something that you're passionate about
and somebody makes fun of it you know
kind of strikes a nerve yeah and it's
also I guess black Black History Month
people pay more attention to anything to
do with that so it's black history month
right now February yeah oh then that's
very purposeful I'm sure and then you
know it's right around President's Day I
have a guess President's Day was Monday
yeah so I mean it's all probably very
purposeful and it's not like our country
is is you know void of
political um upheaval right now there's
a lot of people that are upside on both
sides let's just call us Spade of Spades
sensitive yeah it's sensitive people are
sensitive and so then
comedy becomes sensitive and and I get
it I'm trying to put myself if if that's
me somebody was making fun of something
that like we were doing here it probably
strike a nerve and I probably wouldn't
appreciate
it but this is one of the risks I guess
we take in a society that has free
speech anyway some people were so upset
that they said it feels like a hate
crime if America is moving in this um
Direction where the president's even
appointed a
anti-christian task
force
to I'm not sure what seek out or prevent
either hate speech
or actions against
Christians um you know it's it kind of
makes one wonder where is that
going to go I think it has the potential
to um obviously be a good thing in the
beginning but like everything right
people will get more and more sensitive
and then it'll be more and more like you
know vague in what constitutes is like
that I mean I I personally don't
appreciate Christians or God being put
in a bad light in society so from that
perspective I get it but you just know
that every time you go after one group
you're going to marginalize another or
if you don't agree with that group on
some points it's going to put you in the
you know the outer orbit and then then
it's like well now where do we stand you
know am I an enemy because I don't see
things the same way that you do and that
gets that gets really tricky but anyway
I don't know that I would go that far
but it's an interesting comment and
helps us kind of see where the world is
is
going um and we've seen it work too to
be fair against Christians you know
there have been not that there's been
a um you know a task force the other way
but you've seen how over the M the last
many years Christians have been the
target it seems like of every joke every
you know like you can slam God but you
can't say anything about Muhammad or you
can't say anything about whatever but
you can say anything you want about
Christianity and God and make fun of it
to no end all day long and nobody cares
yeah I mean Buddha is not the butt end
of the jokes not and so from that
perspective I understand you know people
get fed up with it they get tired of it
at the end of the day there probably
could be a lot more Toleration on both
ends it caused me to wonder if Saturday
Night Live had done anything anti-g good
and I'm going to show you something that
I found that was posted by them 3 weeks
ago I'm going to break it into sections
so we can talk a little bit about it
here we
[Music]
go so I'm calling them plants and the
idea is that they inhale carbon dioxide
and exhale oxygen the opposite of
animals so it all balances out that's
really clever have you pitched it to God
yet no I just want to make sure all the
Kinks were worked out my dogs do you
guys mind if I just I just had an idea I
think do it check it out it's like a
mountain right that explodes it explodes
yeah so take the inside of the earth and
it's going to come to the outside it's
going like fireing it's sick anyway
let's get going on these okay hey but
since you're here there's an idea for
something called that's great and I want
to hear about it but let's do exploding
mountains first and hey you guys you're
killing it um wow I mean I yeah it's
obviously a a flip because God did not
come up with the best ideas and if you
notice their ideas were very symbiotic
which is basically how God created the
world right this thing's going to give
to this thing because it needs this
thing and everything's like others
focused and then the little insinuation
that God just wants to come in and
Destroy things yeah good observation
anything from your end or it just seems
that they're putting here like God did
not create the world it's more like
heaven created Earth yes right almost
like a job me meeting they had to pitch
the idea to God so I wrote some things
down that we'll get to towards the end I
just want to see what you guys pick up
in between time and then we can kind of
discuss it as a whole yeah I also think
it's kind of like they're showing you
the character of God by like he doesn't
want to listen just do what to say right
good okay next section of this this is
all one thing but I broke it
up what am I looking at okay what is
this we thought it was good yeah you
thought it was good it's a giant
bouncing rat okay with a camel head in
human arms it's not good I'm sorry and
what's in this pouch on his
stomach those are the um babies they
crawl in there after they're
born get
out once again very insensitive God Y
and then it's like you know he's just
you know everybody's fearful of him
right mhm yeah and and it says well in
reality God did create the kangaroo Okay
no matter if it looks cute cute or not
and the Bible says that God saw that it
was good and in the end when when
creation was completed he said it was
very good yes so here he's just like
what is this sended to Australia where
where you know everything else is but no
it's this is completely opposite from
what God is okay great observations
let's go to the next
one stupid sucks hey guys yeah hi what's
up just wanted flag something with the
humans you asked us to make it so their
private areas felt very good when
they're creating babies well in testing
we realize they can get that same
feeling using their own hands heard yeah
uh I'll tell them not to do that and if
one of them does do it anyway what
should we Straight to Hell forever there
are some things probably in this scene
that that are probably very hard for us
to point out because they're super
vulgar yeah they just portraying God as
this insensitive person that he he
creates pleasure but then it's like he
tells you you know this is off limits
and so it makes him look like he's just
arbitrarily picking what what you should
do and what you shouldn't do when you
open the clip they say we oh interesting
did this yeah that's right you know it's
like they're claiming credit for yeah
carrying out the instructions like God
just said just take care of it and then
they were the creators and it dealing
with self they can do this themselves is
a very like opposite view of what
sexuality is really meant for right
others focused and stuff like that right
okay last little
bit it's really great so good all these
planets and this gravity idea the moons
we killed it yeah totally agreed the
whole solar system honestly slaps like
the planets and then my idea for Gooby
the giant creature with the sun in its
mouth it's like brilliant and then like
all the stars and stuff around it it's
like it really works God about Gooby we
actually think maybe it's a little
better to just have the Sun by
itself oh I don't quite get what here
let me just show you see doesn't that
feel better cuz it's just cleaner it's
NE totally way
cleaner no oh tell them the idea oh yeah
yeah yeah hey God you know what we could
do we could keep Gooby as maybe a small
animal on
earth well what would it what would it
look like like something like this
maybe and there' be a lot of them yeah
they could be everywhere we could put
them in ponds swamps and we'll call them
frogs frogs okay yeah okay I'm good with
that sorry I got a little weird
there yeah I mean it's like you
know God was very intentional with
everything and this just makes it look
like super random he's like a a giant
man child yeah that needs to be taken
care of yeah
and yeah exactly good point so before we
get to some of the the breakdown um one
of the writers for this his name was uh
streer cidel you go back on that you can
see and he's a writer for SNL he was
also a writer for collegehumor.com
and it's this this is an article I found
that he wrote or a little short comic
snippet that they ran in the New York
Times and it was about the first
circumcision and it's I'll just say this
it's the same kind of humor and so you
wonder like okay where did this kind of
thing come from well it's coming from
somebody who has previously done work
that was very Blasphemous the other
thing I found surprising was that
Timothy shalam was involved you well why
is that surprising
yeah he's a dude from Dune is he the one
that was voicing God I'm not sure who he
was voicing cuz he was the only like big
name mentioned on it he was the only big
name mentioned but um he's Jewish he's
actually he is Jewish and Christian so
he identifies as like a Messianic
Interfaith no no um you can see the
picture here this is a picture that his
mom posted on
Instagram and um the caption from from
the article was about how they were they
celebrate Passover and all these
different things so I was like I was
thinking to myself why would somebody
who's Jewish they believe in the
monotheistic God right and at least
that's half of his Heritage and the
other half is is Christian why would you
play Party to something like that like
make fun of God yeah that doesn't make
any sense I think this goes back to the
the probably the way that they're
treating the material in this is fake we
know this is not real this is funny and
we can be you know funny about it or
whatever like this not thinking that
actually jokes and comics and all those
things those have been used over the
years for political to try and sway
people's mindsets over certain things I
mean a comic comic was written way back
when when they when they couldn't like
come out and say something bad about the
leader they draw something funny and
then over time that would change
people's minds of that but they're not
thinking of it like that they're
thinking of it like it's this this just
a joke it's just faith and and I think
God does have a sense of humor but is in
in in a different way in a healthy way
but at the same time uh God does say
that he will he's not someone to be
messed with right you shall not
blaspheme uh I'm a jealous God right
like he he also has feelings you know
yes so some of the things that I wrote
down after watching this was you know
obviously to portray the angels as
creators they showed God as superficial
and
careless God uses euphemisms you know
what a euphemism is it's a substitute
word for a curse word so when he walked
up to the eraser board and he he wiped
that off he said oh my dog m H
interesting right yeah so instead of
saying oh my God he said oh my dog right
just reversing the letters right it
looked like he was wearing Buddhist
prayer beads on his right wrist H
interesting so those are what Buddhist
prayer beads look like and if you roll
back you can see that's what was on his
wrist which is really a slam at like
you're not the only God yeah or that he
prescribes to that Faith interesting
well a lot of people in Hollywood are
are Buddhist yes like Richard
Gear he's not forgiving so when it came
to the sexual Purity piece he was just
like nope Eternal damnation forever you
know send him send him to Hell forever
so in other words you can't repent you
can't be forgiven you can't nothing it
was just like you do that you're done
yeah second death yeah I just just
straight out there's no there's no room
for conversion also that God is a
destroyer in you know the Bible says
that you know I have plans for you to
prosper no plans for you know you to be
destroyed then it's like this is kind of
like putting God as this like yeah his
best ideas he just wants to like blow
some stuff up right they had God's ideas
and God's wisdom being inferior so the
Angels came up with these elaborate
plans and then God comes in with like
cartoon
yeah and it's just a joke comparatively
which is really leaving people with he's
not all wise and all powerful right and
then God is immature like you know he
can't handle handle
criticism he can't handle somebody
else's idea he's just going to break
down you know like he's a two or
three-year-old yeah oh what no giant
frog around the earth and then then he's
like crying the angels have to like oh
no like he's was he's a kid again he's
like oh no it's okay here's a mini
version yeah he's a baby yeah and and
again every everything sounds stupid but
they show things that he actually
created again there was the kangaroo and
then later he drew a a seahorse seah
he's like a that's stupid because the
seahorse male is the one that has the
babies yeah that's why he was like this
is
pouches yeah in the same in the same
skit as the the sexuality one as well
which was interesting
so let's discuss a little bit about what
the Bible says you brought this out and
I'm I'm taking the verse from John not
from Genesis that you made a good point
about when God said when he made
everything on every day he said it was
good he gets to the the final end it's
it's very good but what does it say in
John 1:3 Scotty says all things were
made through him and without him was
nothing made that was made and who is
this talking about talking about Jesus
basically talking about Jesus so really
when you reflect back and and who is
that God mhm that's Jesus that's Jesus
so I want to clarify this for because I
was the one that got in trouble about
saying this from from the first part
right Jesus is a Incarnation meaning he
was in heaven before he came down as
God's son so when we're ascribing the
name Jesus to him it's because we are
not calling him by his pre- Jesus name
but it's the same being yeah and then
Colossians 1:16 I like the way that this
puts it it's just kind of really drives
the point home Felipe would you mind
reading this for by him all things were
created that are in heaven and that are
on earth visible and invisible whether
Thrones or dominions or principalities
or Powers all things were created
through him and for him so he didn't
have Angels working on side projects
really elaborate to create the solar
system or kangaroos or anything else
God's the one that did that and the
thing is if you don't
believe that God can do that and and you
see how he creates it's by his word if
his word isn't powerful to create it's
not powerful enough to do anything in
your life right there's no point in
claiming bible promises because what
good would it do because there's no
creative power there but God has
creative power so when you read his word
you read his promises the same creative
power created the whole universe is
available to change your life so from
second Peter 3:9 it says the Lord is not
slack concerning his promise as some
count slackness but is longsuffering
toward us not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance
so God wants us to repent he's hoping
that we'll repent he's patient for us to
get to that point and he's not just
saying you know what I'm just going to
destroy you I don't care yeah yeah it's
not God it's not the character of God
it's true Isaiah
559 Scotty for as the heavens are higher
than the earth so are my ways higher
than your ways and my thoughts than your
thoughts when we're watching that thing
and it's it's showing
how all these ideas are being put out on
the table by all these
angels what does that say about God it
doesn't say that his thoughts are higher
than our thoughts in fact most of the
time it was portraying their thoughts
are better than his thoughts their ideas
are better than his ideas and this is
not the god that we serve he is so far
above us you know the analogy goes it's
like when Jesus came down from heaven
from you know his lofty State his
intelligent abilities his everything
it's like somebody coming down as a it's
like you as a human becoming an
ant right you're you have a lot more
breadth of knowledge than an ant does
right you could take an ant out a whole
hill of ants out in short order you know
and that's that's kind of the comparison
it's a weak comparison because it's even
greater than that yeah we have limited
understanding of what actually happened
yeah limited comprehension as much as we
think we understand we don't even
understand how much greater God is yeah
than what we are and the last thought
comes from Ephesians
431 and
32 the reason I put is up here Scotty
would you read this and then I'll and
I'll and I'll kind of close with a
thought here let all bitterness wrath
anger clamor and evil speaking be put
away from you with all malice and be
kind to one another tenderhearted
forgiving one another even as God in
Christ forgave you at at the end of the
day none of us like to see our
viewpoints or
ideas um put down or made fun of right
we we generally don't appreciate that
but if we're going to live in a society
where there is Free
Speech then we need to adopt healthy
attitudes towards people that don't
agree with us and it means we still need
to be kind to them we still need to be
loving to them you know we still need to
be forgiving of them and and live our
lives as much like Christ as possible
doesn't mean we have to agree with them
right there going to be plenty of people
in this world you don't agree with but
we should still be respectful of any
kind and you know hold a firm line you
know don't compromise but still be nice
to people if you like this video like
comment subscribe and hit the
notification Bell so you know when we
launch new videos and drop a comments
below and we'll try to get back back to
you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say